[Music]
[Applause]
reggie aloysius miller jr iii the hall
of famer on the call for the mavericks
sons game one last night game two
tomorrow night at 10 eastern on tnt and
reg joins us now reds luca goes for 45.
phoenix got the win what did you think
of their strategy with luca last night
well again uh and this is the luxury
that head coach monty williams uh and
the friends are gonna have in this
series
they've got about seven or eight guys
that are gonna have their turn at
guarding
and
it was a great performance by luca 45
points but he had to struggle
and work for those 45s and they don't
want to give him a steady diet of just
one guys the kell bridges started off on
him but if you saw in that first quarter
there was jay crowder there was chris
paul landry shaman came in cameron
johnson so they're going to just throw a
lot of bodies at him give him different
height perspectives to kind of throw him
off a little bit
but let's face it too
the mavericks did not bring the same
energy and effort that we saw
in those six games versus utah
we didn't see any of that in game one it
was almost like they somewhat exhaled
after
beating utah and now finally getting
into the second round they're going to
have to bring a much better especially
defensive effort they held utah the
number one scoring team to 99 points in
those six games
phoenix drops 121 on them they shot
almost 60 percent for most of the game
they dropped down to about 50 in that
fourth quarter
but there was a glimpse of about six to
eight minutes of that fourth quarter
where the mavericks look like the team
that we thought
this series was going to be about
they've got to extend that for 48
minutes or this could be a very short
series
and i was watching last night you know
luca moves at his own speed but he also
brings the game down to that speed chris
paul is somebody that
i don't think he's
overly athletic but i think he's overly
intelligent that ability to have angles
and find the spots
um
i still marvel at chris paul doing what
he does
and i thought that there's some
similarities at their ability to
kind of bring the game to their pace as
opposed to they have to kind of take
their game to the or you know up to
another pace do you understand that or
agree with that
i absolutely agree one is six seven in
lucca and one is six one and chris paul
and both are the masters at playing
angles that you alluded to
they
don't rush themselves they're not going
to be in a hurry
and they understand where all their
teammates are at one at any point in
time
during
um a point of a game or during a play
it's just it's interesting how they go
about it in somewhat different ways
they're both great at that high
screening role
um and they use again they're not overly
quick
especially in lucca's case but he uses
his size his strength at six seven
and again those angles to be able to get
their shots off but
chris paul look he's gonna turn 37 on
thursday
and
he is arguably
you know charles says this all the time
and i have to somewhat agree with him
he's probably the greatest leader uh
certainly in the game today um but he
just understands how to play the game of
basketball and get the most out of his
abilities and his team's abilities you
don't leave the league in assists for
five years and be at the top of the
mountaintop and at age 37 being able to
do what he has done in these playoffs
in game one versus the pelicans 19
points in the fourth game three the same
thing 19 points
in the fourth and the close out game in
game six goes perfect 14 for 14 and 11
of those were jump shots
i mean
at 37 yeah it's just remarkable
who do you consider a dirtier player or
who does the league consider dirtier
chris paul or draymond green
i wouldn't use dirty on either one of
them
i think both of them use
look they're both not overly athletic
and they use
they're just smart
i wouldn't label either of them dirty
but they're going to do whatever it
takes to win a ball game
i mean see that's like saying was john
stockton dirty yeah players that played
against john stockton say he was dirty
yes but to me john's using his ability
to do whatever it took to win games but
you can still be dirty in using whatever
abilities you have
i would say
like bill that beer to me he was dirty
i was dirty
that's dirty to me that's dirty dirty he
was trying to hurt you
bill and bear was trying to hurt you
yeah draymond green ain't trying to hurt
you but draymond green will do whatever
it takes to win a ball game same with
chris paul i can't label them dirty
who would you label dirty
who you played against
besides lame beer was was rodman dirty
he was molded under reveal that beer
was isaiah was isaiah dirty
he was the captain of the bad boy
keep naming him keep naming him
well joe dumars wasn't dirty
he was he was the gentleman of the dirty
fight
okay he would shake your hands after the
game and say are you all right the rest
of them wouldn't even ask you if you
were all right
but chris paul gets this label and
draymond green gets this label well
they earn this label whatever that label
is
they earn it
i will say this we talked about bill
lambert rodman isaiah draymond
as a competitor against them you hate
him yeah i i didn't like them
i love isaiah but
everyone wanted to play with them i
would want to play with draymond i would
want to play with chris paul bill
lambert if you're on their team
i'm down for whatever that's
look two championships in detroit with
those guys three in golden state and
chris was in the finals last year and
hopefully is working on his first
championship you got to do whatever it
takes to win is draymond a hall of famer
is he going to be a hall of famer
uh yes i do if you look at
his defensive player of the year i think
he's been in the running for that for
the last what four or five years he's
won three championships
um
i think if kimbe mutumbo was in there
ben wallace is a hall of famer draymond
green should certainly be a hall of
famer clay is going to be a hall of
famer stefan obviously is going to be a
hall of famer absolutely and steve kerr
will be a hall of famer
well i'm wondering about that how many
players do you see so if i go greek
freak
you just give me a yes or no yes hall of
famer right luca easy
yes
john morant
i gotta see more body of work jason
tatum
yes
joel embiid
yes
the joker
definitely
joker's gonna win back-to-back mvps
you want an mvp you're automatically in
the only mvp not in the hall of fame as
we speak is derrick rose and he was on
his way to having a hall of fame career
until injuries saddled him do you think
he's going to get in
i hope so
i hope so it's unlikely though jimmy but
i hope so though jimmy butler hall of
famer
wow that's that's a
that's a good one
that is a that's a good one
i will say this
and tim hardaway who
was inducted this year
um but look how long it took for him to
get i think jimmy butler will be on that
route
he'll eventually get in is he a first
second third ballot hall of famer but it
also depends
do the heat wind within the next two or
three years do they want it this year
under jimmy butler that will
help kind of
expedite the process a little bit
kyrie irving hall of famer
yes he has a ring he's yes
first ballot probably not
but again he still has chapters to be
written if he wins another championship
certainly
he could be a first ballot hall of famer
devin booker
i'm putting him in see i love me from d
book and he's so under appreciated
yes he will be a hall of famer and a lot
more chapters to be written because if
the sons into playing a championship
this year
he moves to the front of the line
a lot of these guys
go ahead donovan mitchell
no not yet for chapters to be written
not yet well i know but i'm not talking
about right now but do you think in 10
years from now when we have a
conversation right now his arc his arc
is not trending towards hall of fame
career right now i would say that i'm
just being honest right now it's not
trending that way rudy gobert
yes because i look at rudy like dikembe
he's a three-time defensive player of
the year um yeah he'll he'll be a
hall of famer we're talking to reggie
miller the hall of famer of course
former ucla great and uh indiana pacer
hall of famer you know deandre hopkins
got popped for performance enhancing
drugs
how prevalent do you think
prep performance enhancing drugs are in
the nba
again i i don't think
especially in the game of basketball
i see it in football because i mean look
those guys they take a beating and
they bulk up their bodies
i don't see that in
in the
game of basketball i could be wrong um
yeah but they're doing it in baseball
they're doing i think i just think
they're doing it in
any sport every sport if you can get an
advantage nba it's a grind
and you know what you guys get banged up
uh playing a lot of games there you want
recovery
i i
i i certainly it's all about recovery
it's to me it's all about recovery
because you play 82 games and sometimes
four games in five nights
i could possibly see it
i personally never saw it but i let me
just tell you this
if you told me and i think you know i've
had this conversation before if you told
me there was a pill
that i could take
and i could jump like michael jordan and
i could palm a basketball like michael
jordan and i was as fast as michael
jordan would i take it to compete with
him
i'm not saying
but what i'm saying is what if you're
not getting caught that way what if you
know you're not going to get caught that
way you can tell me that
if i could jump if i could run if i
could if i could ball like that to be on
a competitive level with nj or magic or
bird
i meant that about it people not saying
i would have but boy i would have
thought about it but if nobody found out
about it
and i said i can give you a pill that
will make you have michael jordan
qualities
i'm coming for you black cat
but could you have his personality
though
uh
i will say that you know it's funny
because
i i think last week you were talking
about winning time and the portrayal of
jerry west yeah and how winning time you
know is making him out to be this crazy
all
football baseball players basketball
players we're all crazy
we we're all someone like jerry west
i'm not saying it's true by the way
because jerry is a great guy and i've
known him for 25 30 years the portrayal
is not true of what winning time is but
we all have a bit of
a hole in us all of us are like that
but you didn't punch a teammate did you
like michael did
steve kerr uh yeah i got in a few fights
with my teammates yes i did yes i did
okay yeah i got my behind kick
well you picked on the wrong guys
because everybody was bigger than you
look i got a fight with dale one time
dale davis and he is the me one of the
meanest dudes the game has ever seen and
he beat the olympic crap
it was worth it i got his respect but i
got the crap out of me
but hey
and here was our motto mark jackson i
always said we never
took on a fight with anyone smaller than
us like i couldn't fight
travis best any guards in any guards six
five or below so our rule was six five
are up you had to fight so any power
forward or center it was on but anyone
that was a point guard
you couldn't you couldn't go at because
it wasn't a fair fight you know we
thought we we treated as boxing stick to
your class or up
so yeah i took on dale
and dale beat the living crap he was one
of the fights i had on my team but that
happens all the time
all the time you get into it with your
teammates
you mentioned mark jackson he's uh up to
be uh at least in line possibility to be
a sacramento kings head coach
can't you
jump in front of this and protect mark
from the sacramento kings reggie
if you're a true friend can't you help
mark help himself well
okay well funny you say that because
everyone was saying the same thing when
he took the golden state job what are
you doing who are they steph and who you
guys drafted clay thompson who's this
draymond green kid and he turned them
around no he wasn't there at the end
and got fired after a year or two and
handed it off to steve kerr and they
took it to different levels but you hear
steve kerr always crediting mark jackson
for instilling
the belief that these guys could win so
uh to me it's long overdue what's been
i can't believe it's been this long that
he's been out of the game
i think he could have have the same
thing with sacramento
can he bring them back to the glory days
of vlade dive and chris rubber and og
bobby jackson and mike bibby and paige
no no maybe he can maybe he can no you
know what gets in the way though is the
general manager and the owner so at
least with golden state i probably had a
better chance of developing a team
because ownership
and the gm is not going to impede my
progress like we saw with sacramento
when the owner or g vlade reportedly
didn't want to draft luca because he had
a problem with luca's dad
i will say this
maybe just talking about it we're
sending those positive ways out there to
vladi
and
and to the ownership group
mark alone let him do what he does and
hopefully they can turn it around look i
will say this remark there is only one
way to go with sacramento you can't go
any further down you can't go any
further down they haven't made the
playoffs
in 20 25 years there's only one way to
go so if he can get them into a play-in
situation because the west is going to
be loaded next season
if you can get them into the playoff
situation and pull off what a new
orleans did
and win two games and make the playoffs
it's like winning a championship
but you're right vlade stay out the way
ownership stay out of the way
let me hit you let me hit you with one
more thing here people keep waiting for
us to see the old james harden and i
keep saying no he's just an old james
harden
i mean
he's two and a half years removed from
being a guy who gets 30 points a game
but
he's not even forcing shots
and
now is when you need him to do that
given that joel embiid is out so what
what should you
what will you expect out of james harden
in this series with miami
there's a lot of pressure and let's
remember james harden's history in the
playoffs
right not very good and very
inconsistent play
but this is a chance for james to kind
of change that narrative
because your mvp candidate is gone
probably till game three or four
and you're in the semifinals against a
miami team that
they play it's a culture in miami
defense first we play for one another
like size guys and it's going to be
tough it's going to be rough on james
harden
and we've seen james
shrink up come playoff scene come
playoff time against teams like the
miami heat but this is the
time for him to change the narrative but
he's got to be better and the the sad
thing about it is
i've always felt it when james was
engaged
and more importantly when he was in
shape i just don't think he's ever been
in shape like his mvp years
when he was won the mvp and he was
runner-up two or three years i thought
he was in much better shape and he just
hasn't been
that same james harden the last two or
three years i agree in my opinion that's
just my opinion reggie will be on the
call for uh mavericks sons that'll be
game two tomorrow night at 10 eastern on
tnt thank you reg talk to you next week
it's always a pleasure speaking with you
and dance oh
the best in the biz
are you guys
from 9 00 noon eastern on this show yeah
i like it